[Musique]
un bon soir alexis poulain vaccinodromes
accélération de la stratégie sanitaire
ou futur fiasco alors les fiascos il y
en a eu beaucoup jusqu'à présent c'est
vrai les masques les tests les doses de
vaccins qui n'arrive pas et les
vaccinodromes et on commence à serrer
les dents c'est vrai que la france et
les vaccinodromes ce n'est pas une
histoire d'amour on se rappelle le h1n1
et roselyne bachelot alors ministre de
la santé qui avait ouvert à l'époque des
vaccinodromes qui sont restés
désespérément vides et aujourd'hui mails
macron qui a rechigné à ouvrir ces
vaccinodromes justement compte tenu de
l'histoire ancienne de ceux de ce h1n1
décide finalement de les ouvrir
mais voilà beaucoup de critiques à la
fois parce que les doses n'arrive pas
parce que les vaccinodromes sont en
train de siphonner les doses également
de vaccination départemental les
médecins les élus commencent à dénoncer
la perte de doses quotidiennes
journalières au profit de ces
vaccinodromes rien ne dit que les
français vont aller danser vaccinodromes
qui reste pour certains vie de voir
qu'ils vont fermer parce que les doses
ne sont toujours pas là
on apprend aujourd'hui que pfizer qui
devrait livrer plusieurs millions de
doses à la fin du moral ne livra que
début juin
c'est le cas également d'astrazeneca les
laboratoires n'ont pas été au rendez
vous pourtant merci à monter un commando
qui s'appelle la prod va qu avec un
ancien de sanofi des hauts
fonctionnaires du trésor de bercy de
l'industrie qui vont négocier avec les
laboratoires pour aller récupérer des 12
parce que finalement la politique du en
commun la politique de commander via
bruxelles n'a pas fonctionné ou à
fonctionner à en organisant la pénurie
mais on ne peut pas vraiment le dire
donc il va falloir récupérer ces doses
d'une façon ou d'une autre la prod
vagues peut-être réussir
thierry breton était très fier aussi de
dire que la production revenait sur le
territoire national ni était en visite
en côte d'or à dijon à chenôve à côté de
dijon
c'est loin d'être le cas en réalité ce
sont des sous traitants d'entreprises
allemandes ou internationales qui vont
produire des composants du vaccin
mais le vaccin ne sera pas produit sur
le territoire français donc on est là en
train de se poser la question de dire
est-ce que encore un effet d'annoncé
encore un effet de communication qui va
faire petit ça commence à faire beaucoup
et là ça commence je pense à inquiéter
également l'exécutif alors il ya une
autre annonce la production en france
qui commence demain même si il faut le
préciser une partie des doses vont
partir à l'étranger
oui alors non seulement nous allons
produire sur le territoire français et
européens mais nous sommes fiers
d'exporter plus que nous en gardons sur
le territoire européen
et c'est vrai que au delà de produire le
problème des composants du vaccin reste
essentiel aujourd'hui nous sommes
tributaires de l'étranger nous ne sommes
pas indépendants sur la production de
doses de vaccins nous faisons de
l'embouteillage du flaconnage c'est à
dire que nous mettons les produits dans
des flacons nous faisons de la
production de nanoparticules denanot
lipides de d'outils qui vont permettre à
produire ce vaccin mais pour ce qui est
des composants ils ne sont pas produits
ici en france et sur le territoire
européen c'est encore loin d'être le cas
donc une pénurie est possible égaler le
fait de dire que les vaccins sont
françaises c'est loin d'être le cas
aujourd'hui c'est priseur bio ntech ses
astra zeneca et astrazeneca
on le voit il ya une défiance
grandissante des populations parce que
l'agencé européenne du médicament
commencé à avoir des doutes
c'est certaines thrombose veineuse qui
sont graves qui sont certes rares voire
extrêmement rare mais qui arrive et qui
pousse à la défiance vis-à-vis de cette
de ce vaccin
pourtant produit sur le sol européen ça
en fait beaucoup
et pourtant l'europe rechignent toujours
à commander des vaccins auprès de la
russie avec spoutnik v ou de la chine
ce sera uniquement en juin que
l'autorité européenne du médicament
donnera un avis pour la mise sur le
marché de ces vaccins là donc on est en
train d'organiser une pénurie
néanmoins emmanuel macron et le
ministère de la santé reste optimiste et
continue de viser les dix millions de
primo vacciner en avril
1 millions en mai et les 38 en juin ça
on ne sait pas ça commence à être un peu
plus flou il ne se cache pas que ce sera
extrêmement tendue parce que les
livraisons n'arrive pas au rythme
demandé et la vaccinodromes ou pas on
reste dans le flou total
quant à ses objectifs et dans ce
contexte tendu alexis la sphère
pierre-jean chalencon mais le
gouvernement un petit peu dans
l'embarras quand même hein et alors une
journée exceptionnelle c'est à la fois
l'anniversaire de la république en
marche cinq ans que le parti
présidentiel a été créé et est
aujourd'hui il semblerait qu'à ministre
aurait été aperçu un dîner clandestins
c'est la société des journalistes de m6
qui le dit dans un communiqué de presse
ce soir en disant non nous ne faisons
pas d'échec news
nous enquêtons nous attendons de savoir
qui est cette personne
pourtant tout a été fait pour minimiser
cette affaire en disant que non c'était
un poisson d'avril pierre jean salençon
ce collectionneur femme de napoléon
propriétaire de l'hôtel de ville vienne
qui organise ces dîners est en train de
s'expliquer en disant qu'il est à
farceur et que c'était un poisson
d'avril
toute la cellule riposte du parti
présidentiel est vent debout pour dire
que c'est scandaleux de parler sans
savoir
néanmoins les journalistes de m6 en
quête d'autres journalistes
d'investigation sont en train d'essayer
de savoir qui était présent à ces dîners
clandestins et des dîners clandestins
oui il y en a et c'est insupportable
pour les français qui se voient eux
obligés de payer des amendes de 400
euros quand il débouche une bouteille de
rosé entre amis sur une plage alors que
r jean salençon lui mettait les photos
de ces dîners sur les réseaux sociaux en
se vantant d'être l'ami de brigitte
macron des ministres est très fière
d'organiser ces dîners clandestins il ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas au royaume
de france
tout est en train d'un peu de se bloquer
comme les ent la façon de donner cours à
distance
aujourd'hui on pensait que le ministère
de l'éducation a été près un an après
alors que les écoles fermées aujourd'hui
à donner des cours en ligne
il n'en était rien jean-michel bancaire
a tenté en vain d'accuser des hackers
étrangers d'ailleurs je crois que les
réseaux sociaux ne se sont pas privés de
se moquer de cette excuse
il ya quelque chose qui ne marche plus
chez en marche et ça commence à se voir
oui je vous confirme les bugs
aujourd'hui le toit alexis dans une
campagne politique présidentielle qui
s'installe valls mélenchon jadot
bertrand retailleau philippa et j'en
passe oui le climat est exceptionnel
c'est vrai que pour ses 5 ans en marche
et gâtés il a beaucoup de cadeaux
d'anniversaire beaucoup de candidats à
la présidentielle alors les candidats
officiels déclaré marine le pen qui
essaye de se glisser dans la peau d'une
candidate mainstream un peu policé qui
va essayer de séduire la droite
traditionnelle et d'être cette candidate
de droite finalement et plus d'extrême
droite xavier bertrand qui va essayer
d'incarner un nouveau nicolas sarkozy
avec des valeurs de la droite le travail
et puis d'autres choses des candidats à
droite aussi qu'ils sont soumis déclaré
comme l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe qui n'osent pas dire qu'il
pense quand même on ne se rasant pas
puisqu'il est paru à la présidentielle à
gauche jean luc mélenchon candidat
déclaré mais aussi yannick jadot d'une
certaine façon qu'ils essayent
d'enjamber la primaire d'europe écologie
les verts en disant qu'il faudrait faire
une candidature unique à gauche et puis
anne hidalgo qui ne pensent pas qu'à la
mairie de paris quand elle met des
petits bacs pour végétaliser les rues de
paris et qui pense bien sûr au pays
et pourquoi pas une présidente en 2022
après tout ça fait beaucoup de
prétendants emmanuel macron lui va sans
doute se représenter même si son bilan
risque d'être impacté énormément par
cette gestion calamiteuse de la crise
sanitaire
on se rappelle bien sûr des mensonges
sur les masques on se rappelle des
fiascos sur les tests on se rappelle là
maintenant on les voit les vaccins qui
ne sont pas là les excuses de jean
michel blanquer air sur les ent qui
plante le jour où l'école est fermée
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
fiasco beaucoup de flops
néanmoins pour le moment tout reste
ouvert
la présidentielle c'est dans un an mais
ça commence à occuper beaucoup les
esprits et peut-être avec chance ça va
ça c'est le co vide et on va commencer à
parler d'autre chose
merci on aimerait bien avec 6 pour l'un
merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france